[Musique]
cavalier du grand
retour nous avons
prué tant de vie et tant
d'amour pour nos
liberté cavalier si Dieu le
veut nous serons rentrés
[Musique]
par la poudre et par le
feu dans notre
[Musique]
cité chanterons ce
soir la grande
victoire sur
guitare tu auras sur la peau du sang
d'espagnolur
content le pas
triomphant le tou battant
cavalier du grand
retour faut plier ton
camp aujourd'hui c'est le grand
jour le canon
attend
[Musique]
Santa
Maria faor
una
para Santa Maria por
fa n mi
[Musique]
de
cavalier si Dieu le
veut nous aurons de
l' nos enfants seront
heureux jusqu'après la
mort Rosita Rosita Rosita Rosita Rosita
je tiendrai ta
main comme un bon
au vendredi
saint Rosita Rosita Rosita
Rosita nous serons les
rois au grand
carnaval de
Christoval
cavalier du grand
retour faut plier ton
camp aujourd'hui c'est le grand
jour liberté
attend
[Musique]
cav